Chumlee Captain Marvel shall we
Marvel vs. Capcom infinite represents
the most significant change to the
series's formula since its creation and
the result is a game that's both fun and
rewarding to play for series veterans
and newcomers alike however the whole
experience is let down by lackluster
presentation the biggest shake-up in
Marvel vs. Capcom Infinite comes with
the addition of the Infinity stones
which in Marvel Law correspond to a
different facet of the universe
space-time mind reality soul and power
one stone can be taken into battle
alongside two fighters and each of them
has a unique ability called infinity
surge that can be used just like any
other special move these abilities open
the door to a world of creative combos
setups and strategies that the series
has never had before the Infinity stones
encourage players to make characters
their own and they offer the tools to
forge distinct play styles a Hulk player
is now empowered to negate his slow
movement speed by using the time stones
teleport function an aggressive Dante
can use a soul stones health sapping
capabilities to mitigate damage from
risky strategies or a thorough scan
cover his lumbering approach with the
reality stones homing fireball despite
the attributes these stones bestow each
character still retains what makes him
distinct among the cost
so although Hulk might have a teleport
trying to play him like Strider won't
work new finding stones also have a
secondary ability called infinitely
storm which is charged by surge usage
when unleashed they unlocked the full
potential of the stone and give its user
a big short-term advantage power boost
damaged mind refills hyper combo meter
soul revives fallen allies time
eliminates recovery on move so they can
be chained together easier space
restricts movement and reality gives
elemental properties to attacks infinity
stone briefly changes the parameters of
battle in favor of the user but still
gives the other player the ability to
fight on through smart play and strategy
so using it creates an authentic moment
of tension and drama
the other big change to Marvel vs.
Capcom formula is in the tagging system
which has been simplified but not
without sacrificing depth at the press
of a button a teammate will sprint into
the fray to take over allowing players
to extend combos for greater damage or
set up tricky situations that can
potentially penetrate defenses teammates
will always enter on the ground which
means low effort health melting chained
air combos are a thing of the past
while it's not impossible to make combos
go on for absurdly long it's hard work
since the character being tagged out is
slow to leave this place is high
execution demands and strict timing
requirements on players who need to keep
the combo going long enough to cover the
tagged cooldown it might be frustrating
to find yourself on the receiving end of
one of these multi tag combo strings but
you can be sure that the player on the
other side is putting in the work to
make it happen similarly infinite isn't
as liberal with giving characters off
the ground moves that can extend combos
easily fewer characters have them now
and those that do have a very limited
opportunity to pull them off again when
you see one happen you know it was well
executed between the new tag system and
the diminished role of ot G's infinite
feels like a much more grounded game
than its predecessors it moves at a
slower pace than series veterans may be
used to but also feels more honest in
finished mechanics feel much more
open-ended which paves the way for more
creative play well the casual player
Infinite has a one button auto combo
system that lets players pick up a
controller and make Col stuff happen
quickly and easily by repeatedly
pressing just the light punch bar and
you can execute a full combo starting on
the ground launching into the air and
finishing with an over-the-top hyper
combo
however Auto combos do considerably less
damage than a manual combo so a serious
player shouldn't have any trouble
against someone just doing Auto combos
the system is a simple and intuitive way
to get people started and for those that
want to dig a little deeper Infinite has
a comprehensive mission mode that will
walk play through the basics of movement
attacking how Infinity stones work and
how they can be incorporated into play
on top of that each character has ten
individual missions that start with
basic special moves but escalate into
high execution combos
Capcom's last major fighting game Street
Fighter 5 was criticized for its dearth
of content at launch but this criticism
can't be leveled at Marvel vs. Capcom
infinite in addition to the training
modes there's versus a classic arcade
mode a suite of online modes including
ranked and casual matches the beginners
League and a Lobby system all vs. Capcom
infinity netcode has shown itself to be
reliable in finding matches and for the
most part those matches are stable in
network performance much making speedy
often finding an opponent to battle it
out with quickly and when both players
have full connections it feels as smooth
as playing offline naturally with lower
connection strengths the experience is
more prone to star and on rare occasions
freeze for a second or two however this
is at the very low end of the spectrum
even with middling connections gameplay
isn't noticeably impacted one of the
smart touch a--'s in its online mode is
the beginners League which pits players
ranked 14th and lower against each other
by winning their crew points and once
they graduate out of the league is no
longer accessible making it the ideal
way to find footing in the dog-eat-dog
world of online Marvel vs. Capcom the
post match options also make it easier
to keep fights rolling as it provides
the opportunity to rematch or find a new
player immediately without being kicked
back into the online section the other
big draw in Marvel vs. Capcom Infinite
is the story mode which is actually
quite good it's a simple narrative but
the characterization really shines
through spider-man is a wisecracking
goof Tony Stark always thinks he knows
better Hulk smashes and cap motivates we
need a fourth
we need the soul stone there's a light
humorous quality to everything and the
story takes the opportunity to poke fun
at yourself when it can
it's unfortunate then that Marvel vs.
Capcom Infinite is really let down by
its presentation while characters like
Captain Marvel Thanos cheddar and Gamora
looked vibrant and detailed the faces of
human characters of very rough ranging
from vacant looking for our youth to
downright ugly for poor Frank West it's
a shame because the different arenas
fights take place in are very cool
mashups of Marvel and Capcom locales
that carry the game's all-star crossover
ethos through nicely the menus in
inferno are all so dull and life
this might seem like nitpicking at
something insignificant but as a fan I
felt really let down Marvel vs. Capcom 3
felt like a celebration of the two
universes it's a game bursting with
reverence for the source material
it starts screen literally screamed the
name of the game at you like that kid
opening a Nintendo 64 on Christmas
morning its character select is a comic
book that you flip through and
characters make references to existing
relationships or obscure storylines
before they battle by comparison
infinite is bereft of enthusiasm Marvel
vs. Capcom 3 is that person at
convention wearing an elaborate Dormammu
outfit complete with a flaming head
infinite is that person wearing a plain
black t-shirt with a Marvel logo on it
nevertheless the mechanics underlying
Marvel vs. Capcom infinite make it an
outstanding fighting game Capcom has
understood what caused the stagnation of
Marvel vs. Capcom 3 competitive scene
and to some extent the issues Street
Fighter 5 currently faces in response
it's created a fighting game focused on
individuality and expression with deep
systems that reward studious players but
also accommodate casuals as someone who
both plays and watches fine games I'm
excited to see what the future holds for
Marvel vs. Capcom infinite
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]